we are three days away from the final
four in the nfl the nfc and afc
championship games and both of them
should be great both are rematches of
games that we saw during the regular
season and both games during the regular
season were very exciting and arguably
could have gone either way we spent time
talking about patriots chiefs last hour
this one saints and rams remember the
saints had the big lead the rams pulled
their way back into it and then the
saints found a way to pull away at the
end of the game went back and forth and
again this one could go either way i
don't think the saints are as explosive
now as they were back in november when
they played the rams the rams dipped
through a couple of weak games and then
they have come back strong and they took
care of the cowboys and chris you know i
i felt like i'm leaning saints all week
but you could make a good argument for
the rams to go in there with the
experience of having played in that very
loud superdome to go back there not be
deterred not be intimidated and get it
done yeah exactly right i mean i
certainly would not be shocked if the
rams won this football game the rams are
a very talented team they're well
coached on both sides of the ball and
and let's not forget you know it was
21-14 the rams drive right down the
field and they tried the fake field goal
do you remember that mike and then the
sa they didn't get it the saints went
down and scored made it 28-14 then on
the very next play jared goff throws an
interception the saints scored again to
make it 35-14 and the rams came back
just like that and all of a sudden it
was 35 35 and of course the saints put
the game away by scoring the last 10
points but i'm also interested right to
see which coach you know has the guts to
call the big trick play or whatever it
may be in the moment both of these
coaches have been fearless in those
situations all year long sean payton his
whole career and mcveigh for the first
two years of his career i you know i
mean i guess these two would be the guys
you would say have called the most fake
punts fake field goals they do it all
and the constant pressure these court
these coaches put on you not only with
their offensive game planning but the
things they do with the special teams
unit as well
those are little plays i look at that
could be the edge or the difference in
the game like sean payton faking the
punt last week and really jump starting
his football team
aggressive aggressive aggressive
aggressive we saw the chiefs go for it
on fourth down four times last week tom
brady talked yesterday about how the
patriots may have to do the same thing i
mean you're gonna have to score points
when you can so when you get to fourth
and two on the opposing team's 47 you
you can't be
deterred from trying to keep possession
of the ball because you know we saw it
with the patriots in the chargers last
week if you don't match a team score for
score you're going to fall into a hole
that you may not climb out of and that
happened to the rams last time around
they climbed out of the hole to their
credit the saints were able to pull away
and win the game what give me one of the
big matchups you're looking at as we
focus on this nfc championship game well
i mean kind of what we saw in the
opening and it was only on tv but for
the radio folks was the of course the
matchup of uh marcus peters versus
michael thomas or really just how are
the rams defense going to match up with
michael thomas this time around the rams
defense is a little different than they
were in the first matchup they played a
lot more man-to-man during that time of
the year and they've kind of adjusted
now and they're more of a zone coverage
type of football team where they just
sprinkle in a little man every now and
then to keep you off balance but what is
wade phillips going to do to michael
thomas in certain situations you know
last week there was a few plays where uh
the rams doubled some of the receivers
on on the cowboys in certain formations
will they do that with michael thomas
michael thomas his greatness is his
physicality and his ability to catch the
ball over the middle he's not
necessarily going to scare you with his
speed or things like that but it's how
peyton moves him around and puts him in
different positions and he can
compromise your coverages with how he
does put him in a bunch set or makes
them the slot receiver and oh gosh now
we've got to change our rules we wanted
to double them so when they do go man do
they put a cube to lead bottom who's a
little bit more of a bigger more
physical true man-to-man corner than
marcus peters is who wants to play off
coverage more or do they just say no and
we're just going to double team him if
he's on our side that's the one thing i
look at because they were absolutely
killed with mike by michael thomas the
first time around 211 yards i believe 12
receptions and if that happens again the
saints are going to win the football
game
and he had 12 for 171 and a touchdown on
sunday against the eagles and before
that game there was a moment where drew
brees talked to the players out on the
field to get them fired up you know the
standard thing that we see all the time
and brees gave a very impassioned and
and compelling speech but if you watch
that and i encourage anyone out there to
go find this watch michael thomas while
brees is talking to the team watching
him is scarier than anything brees has
to say that guy has himself whipped into
a frenzy i don't want to have to try to
stop that guy with one two or three
defenders he is determined to make
things happen he is determined to beat
you and we saw it on sunday we've seen
it in big games this year he's had 180
yards 129 211 there have been some other
games where he tails off but i think
part of it is they use him as a decoy
because if you are going to take him out
of the game we got other guys that can
get it done but on a game like this on a
platform like this he's going to get his
catches he's going to get his yards and
he's going to be every bit as lathered
up against the rams as he was against
the eagles you know it and i mean look
at some of these plays it's not like the
coverage is bad here by by marcus peters
it's not like he's getting toasted he's
there but
michael thomas is the best receiver in
traffic in football that's where he's
amazing you can cover him and he's just
going to go up and manhandle with his
hands there there's one where he runs by
him and that's where they're going to
have to be careful in those type of
situations do you really want to get
down there and jam a michael thomas in
the slot because he could throw you out
of the way and then you're done and it's
it's bye-bye so they'll have to
re-evaluate how they do that uh but it
is he's he is a physical tough football
player who's fearless and the rams
certainly you're gonna have to have a
different game plan against him this
time around
well and for the uh for the saints on
defense right they're gonna have to have
a game plan for this new rushing attack
that's right the rams have put together
because you've got cj anderson who's got
three straight 100 plus yard games and
todd gurley completely off the injury
report on wednesday sean mcveigh had
said he'd be limited in practice they
had a walkthrough yesterday but he
wasn't even listed as fully
participating with the knee injury no
mention of a knee injury gurley is fine
girly's fine anderson's getting it done
they better have an answer in the front
seven to avoid having holes blown open
like they were against the cowboys and
to to get to these guys once they get
through to the second level because it
was a failure last week by one of the
best defenses in football
273 total rushing yards and also by
using that approach what does it do
chris it keeps drew brees in company on
the sidelines that's exactly right mike
and you know again we've seen lately
jared goff has not been you know the
jared goff that we saw in the middle of
the year or the guy that we saw go into
new orleans and throw for 391 yards and
three touchdowns and yes uh i think this
will be a big factor in the game the the
rams are the number three running
offense in football the same to the
number two run defense in football
something's got to give here and i do
think for the rams to win this game you
know the first time around they only
gave the ball to gurley 13 times uh as
far as running the football they're
gonna have to up that number and
dominate the line of scrimmage a little
bit more one to help jared goff uh and
two sean payton is i mean i'm sorry sean
mcvay is is an amazing play-action pass
game plan designer and he needs to keep
the the saints in check with that alone
and and that'll help give goff some
confidence goff again last week was
solid but not great and he is something
that i do worry about a little bit in
this matchup because we just haven't
seen the same guy over the last five six
weeks of the season
making it harder too for the saints to
stop anderson and gurley the absence of
sheldon rankins who tore and killed in
the first quarter last week so it hurts
that saints run defense the numbers
suggest that when he's not on the field
the saints give up more yards per carry
far more yards per carry than when he's
on the field he and he won't be on the
field but anderson and gurley will be
give me another match-up you're looking
at for the nfc championship game well i
think that you know you got to look at
the other side of the story there with
the run game as well you know that
that's what i think is fascinating i
mean the you know the patriots the rams
uh the saints they're all like you know
in the top of football as far as running
the football and one of the big issues
for the rams all year has been run
defense they've been sloppy i mean sue
and aaron donald kind of just do their
own thing at times during the year and
it's left them to be a team that lets up
122 yards per game
running the football but last week they
played really disciplined football
against the dallas cowboys sean payton
the saints they want to run the ball
first with the two-headed monster and
camara and ingram and if if they start
running the ball on the rams the rams
are in deep trouble so you know aaron
donald sue they're gonna have to have
another performance like we saw against
the dallas cowboys last week where they
stay true to the defense they do what
they're supposed to do no freelancing no
oh i'm going to shoot the gap and go
make a play because if they do that too
often it's going to be oh damn i've left
my hole and then it's going to be alvin
kamara through the middle for a 40-yard
gain so i look at that again as the
discipline of the rams d-line can they
keep that up and you know stop the
saints from just absolutely overpowering
them in that in that part of the match
up first time around you know the saints
ran the ball pretty damn well against uh
that rams defense how you feeling about
these two games from a pick standpoint i
mean we'll finalize our picks tomorrow
but i i could see either team winning
either game i am like in toss-up mode i
just really finished my my film
breakdowns like the last two days where
i did deep dives into all four
divisional games and like i'm sitting
here right now i have a lean i'm not
gonna tell it yet but i i feel like this
is like the most coin flip afc nfc
championship weekend that i can ever
remember i mean i really do it's it's
hard there's so many intriguing matchups
within the matchups and then great
coaching who can add wrinkles to the
game plan that we might not think of and
go oh man that was a great way they
exposed this scheme or that scheme so
that's where i'm really intrigued and uh
yeah i'm not gonna give you any tells
until tomorrow you're not cheating off
my picks yet sorry
oh trust me i i listen uh other than the
fact that we agreed on the chiefs on
saturday i'm i'm i'm not i'm not looking
to to peek over your shoulder that's for
damn i'm seven and one so far in the
playoffs i'd just like everybody to know
that seven and one you're seven and i i
i wanna see the proof seven and one i
don't believe that i did go back i get
wrong i got wrong the bears eagles i
picked that's right right that's the
only one i've gotten wrong so far in the
playoffs
that was a pretty big one that was a big
one yes but i stayed with i got it right
and i picked the saints i picked the
saints last week and damn i was nervous
when they were down 14 nothing
oh i was feeling pretty good when they
were down 14 nothing because i picked
the eagles and you know what's funny
i've had people on twitter who are
saints fans like call me out it's like
wait a minute that's a little bit much
right because you were probably soiling
your pants in the first quarter don't
don't act like the game went the way you
thought it was gonna go saints fans
right you dodged a bullet on that one
don't you don't come out and flex after
that game that's one where you just run
and you hope they don't change their
mind and give the eagles the ball back
with a chance to try to score the game
to score down the stretch and win the
game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports